morning thank you for coming press  conference was great because I was a bit  nervous at the beginning but we had a  lot of fun the other actors so I start  to really feel involved in the project  I play the role of a suffering the first  time you you see her she has a dark side  I was in a way convinced that I could  bring something interesting as an  actress I think there is a big range of  colors when playing a Bond girl whether  they are very nice or good characters or  villainous or Psychopaths so it is very  interesting because you can try to  create your own character based on that  I think this is very particular to the  James Bond movies